question
all right master jay and lil mama
uh where you guys from well i'm
originally from galveston texas
um been out here pretty much
all my life i've been all over
um california
from where you grow up
i grew up in inglewood california
and master j where you from originally
i'm from ohio
and um so
little mama is one of your girls this is
my bottom it's your bottom
bottom [ __ ] as you say that's right and
how many girls do you have
i had the most is five right now i only
have three
uh how did you guys grow up how did you
grow up master j
well i grew up homeless well i grew up
with a single parent
and uh i you know i just wanted to
find out what was going on i went you
know found some friends and then run
across
you know i had my first hole at the age
of 13. they were 16 years old
you see them i just have them go up in
the school bathroom and
turn tricks and give me their lunch
money or whatever else
they have and where did you learn that
that was a possibility at 13
however i met a pimple out there on
figaro
he was my friend he took me under his
wing i needed extra money come
my my mom couldn't give me everything
she you know i wanted
i had big dreams and she couldn't
fulfill it and so i wanted to help the
household
and that's where i got the idea at right
there and you've been doing it ever
since
i've been doing it ever since so the
arrangement
little mama is what you give master jay
all of your money
pretty much i mean he see i don't mind
giving him all of the money because he
also when i give him all the money he
gives me money too
like for myself he takes care of you
yeah so
pretty much you know um i give it to him
because
he you know is in control of
you know making sure we have food and
and clothes
and toiletries and stuff like that
because we're homeless
you know and um it's what you call i'm
just a business manager right there and
i know pimp i'm not a player i'm just a
business manager
what it is i make sure she have what she
needs with what she get
she earned i just get a percentage of
what it is you see what i'm saying
and if she gets in trouble with one of
her i am i am the one
you you come back yes i also i also
have associates to handle such so you're
a little bit of protection for her as
well
most definitely no one messes with
master jay's girls
have even prison time excuse me have you
done prison time
or did not answer that question okay
and if little mama gets arrested which
is not such a she's well taken care of
yeah
and how much how much will you make a
night little mama
it varies um
i made like on a slow on the slow
on a slow day it's like five
um to a a rack
it's like five to a thousand
but um i make like fifteen hundred to
two thousand dollars a day
oh really
have you had bad experiences with some
of the guys that pick you up
what kind of stuff has happened i mean
i've had them play games with me i mean
you know i don't know what the
intentions are but like
to be honest with you i did a date
the other day for a couple hundred
dollars right
and um you know come to find out they
were all fake 20.
they're paying you with fake money yeah
so i was you know it kind of
that pissed me off but i guess that's
how life is
and you've been doing this since how
long little mama i've been
pretty much all my life
um what age did you start i started like
okay i'm thinking because i had my son
at the age of
18. so i pretty much
got out there at 19 years of age
and i'm 43 now
and tell me about how you grew up you
had both parents
uh well the thing about that is that
they divorced when very early
so i was always moving around you know i
went from
staying with mom to staying with dad
to staying with grandma you know
having um
you know step parents and
you know
so i mean i can't say that i was i was
poor
you know but it i wasn't
born with a silver spoon in my mouth any
abuse when you were a kid
physical sexual any like that no
and master jay what personality traits
do you have that help you do this
not everyone can be a pimp right i know
everyone can be a pimp no
but you have to do well see i'm i'm i'm
more of like a
of service i like to consider myself
just a
you know service to the public there's a
lot of lonely men out there there's a
lot of people that likes coming you know
men and women
and i come i've always been a people
person
so what i do there is i just you know
give them what they need
but they can't find on their own you
know this to bring
joy in one's life you know that's my mom
i got them i got the top and
you know my babies yes you can see very
beautiful i don't i don't
you know have nothing under that you
know if they ain't attend
i don't want to work with them
and what's what is your style i've
talked to a lot of pimps and some are
ladies men they're smooth talkers some
guys they're a little more aggressive
it's not a uh i would consider myself as
just being a realist
and a freestyle i'm a free spirit man uh
you know you have your choice you know i
give you the opposite you know
opportunity to do something for yourself
i like them to go to school i like them
to do their thing it's all about them
it's all about bringing them up
picking them up not tearing them down
you see what i'm saying
uh you know i had a couple you know i
worked with for maybe a year or
something like this
they got out the game they went to
school while they was doing it and now
they
you know professional career women
do you think the relationship between a
pimp and a prostitute is
sometimes a
a recreation of the father-daughter
relationship that a lot of these women
had or didn't have
that's a good question there my man but
the thing is a lot of us you have a lot
of lonely women out there that want that
father figure
you see what i'm saying but you you know
you have to balance it out
yes i'm dad but i'm also your friend
your family yeah yeah you're in your
business manager you're their boyfriend
you're their daddy
that's it right there you have to be all
things in one i'm your superhero
i'm all of that in one you guys have
children
i'm sorry no no we don't
you guys been in love before excuse me
have you been in love
we're in love now he was in love at
first sight
and yes um
i just wanted to make a comment
as far as the
camp and prostitution thing it it can be
a together thing you know um
but you know there's also cases where
it's like you know a separate a separate
thing because
like ones are for themselves
but that's not the case
are drugs a part of the picture for you
guys
it was once uh
and it all depends on what you call
drugs see alcohol is a drug
so it all depends on what you call drugs
never got into anything heavy
you know drink something you'll find
someone they'd like to do
you know this or that we'll put it that
way
without you know incriminating ourselves
little mama do you do you find being a
little high helps you do this
every night yeah i mean i'm going to
keep it real we're trying to survive
period point blank you know what i'm
saying you know we have to
we don't have any you know paperwork or
anything so
we have to try to keep a room you know
what i mean we have to eat
we have to so it all goes together
it all goes together with us there you
know
i mean sometimes there's drugs sometimes
there's not
sometimes no and you guys are basically
living from hotel room to hotel room
yeah we try to
we pretty much try to go to the same
place and get a room every day
um and do business out of that room
um i kind of that's really for us
so i have to do my business like around
it
but like i say we're trying to survive
we are trying to survive that's honest
you know we're looking for we're trying
to we talk and we're trying to make up
plans for other
you know resources do you think you're
addicted to this lifestyle
either of you i mean do you think this
lifestyle is addicting
yeah it can be very addicting and i'm
glad
that i'm at the point where i'm pretty
much hungry
you're over it yeah i just
i'm ready to just just do some uh
normal what was the best time of your
life
it was the best time of my life
whoa i've had
you know i guess
a few different times and that that's
kind of hard
that's and that was kind of hard what
was the worst time of your life
the worst time
oh being separated from from my family
are you close to your families today i'm
trying to be
does your family not approve of what
you're doing
do you get to get depressed sometimes
little mama yeah
yes it's a rough way to spend your days
right
what do you think most squares don't
understand about the game what what what
are outsiders not that it's one of the
oldest professions in the world
and it's it's to bring joy they look
down when they look down
on you know on my business associates
you know it it it bothers me you know
and i just say uh it's it's for the
enjoyment i mean
it's you know they you know like they
they dirty but they're not
they bring in joy they ought to bring
joy
you know at their expense
you see but a square always go look down
until they get
bit oh once they get bit by that for
being apple
then they more like hey they spend more
than a banker
is sometimes uh is it sometimes uh
not exactly just sex for money sometimes
you're getting the watch or the jewelry
or the
wallet or something like that money from
the guy um
does that happen i mean it has
you know but it's not really about that
i mean don't get me wrong
you know there are good times where you
don't have to really i
i don't have to i don't i'll be with
someone and they'll spend money on me
for a while and i'm not i don't even do
anything
just to have company see just to be
event
a lot of men out there just want
somebody to talk to have a prelay on
their side
they fantasize in their head and they go
home with their wife or their boyfriend
or whoever
what's the craziest thing you've seen in
your years of doing this
oh my my my
well i've seen i've seen
why on both ends i've seen you know i've
seen women get
mutilated uh
none of my business associates is but
i've seen other women getting muted
i've seen men get you know tore up
you know it's just i mean it's wild
that's why you have to pick and choose
and i always ask my associates just
don't jump into any car
on a you know on a dream just don't jump
in any car
be picky be choosy
you said i'm saying because you know who
knows a cycle could be your past
no mama do you find you have to use your
intuition sometimes with
with customers other guys that you'll
just say no to
yeah yeah
how has the game changed you've been
doing this for a while with the
you know the the flashy dressers and the
fancy cars and all that that
yeah it and i mean it's widespread i
mean the way uh
the cost of living and all that with
everything has changed the economy
technology yeah the comedy is changed
now
you know uh the women is getting much
younger
to where that's how we you know i come
up with going out of state you know
state to state to state you know what
i'm saying because it's getting
and and the drugs have a lot to do with
it the addictions
is driving the line women you have a lot
more renegade women out there
you know so called working for their own
uh just like that
you know and just it's just it's not the
same as the old days
you guys will travel to other states
yeah we've been
we've been places but we put you know on
business but we're yet to go
you know like you said we we come down
to our retirement days
now it's time to get back
little picket fence house with the
picket fence
lots of kids all right master jay and uh
hello mama thank you so much for talking
with me and
good luck with where you guys go from
here and thank you for having us
[Music]
show me the money
you